John Legend Justin Timberlake Brad
Paisley and more stars support the
Dodgers during the World Series Game two
of the World Series went down on
Wednesday night in LA as the Dodgers
faced off against the Houston Astros
plenty of Hollywood's elite was there to
cheer on the home team's legendary
Dodgers announcer Vin Scully helped
throw out the first pitch
while Brad Paisley sang the national
anthem Jessica Biel and hubby Justin
Timberlake entered the stadium hand in
hand showing it their supports in LA
Dodger caps yeah it's crazy John Legend
cheered on the team alongside friend and
photographer Mike Rosenthal while Kate
Upton was spotted in the stands
supporting her man Astros pitcher
Justin Verlander the celeb turnout was
just a star studded during Game one
after all it marks the first time the
Dodgers have made it to the World Series
since 1988 et was there on Tuesday to
get their take on the historic moment
awesome is it to be them back in the
world after 29 years this is a strong
team they play well together it's about
time you know right will we belong so
let's just do it you know it's time to
just put four games together and win
this thing
[Music]